IN REALITY, JOE BIDEN WAS THE
ONE WORKING TO PURGE CORRUPTION
FROM UKRAINE.
>> Sean: THEY ARE NUTS.
HERE WITH REACTION, THIS BOOK
JUST OUT TODAY, Amazon.com,
Hannity.com, BOOKSTORES
EVERYWHERE, PERFECT TITLE,
"TRIGGER, HOW THE LEFT THRIVES
ON HATE AND WANTS TO SILENCE
US."
ALSO EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION,
DONALD TRUMP JR.
I WILL TAKE THE BAIT.
I HEARD YOUR DAD, WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IF HE WAS THE
VICE PRESIDENT, HE SHOOK DOWN
AND LEVERAGED A BILLION
TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN A QUID PRO
QUO JOE, AND YOU ARE GETTING
PAID MILLIONS WITH NO EXPERIENC
EXPERIENCE.
>> OBVIOUSLY IT WOULD BE FINE,
SEAN.
I TOOK AN UNSOLICITED PHONE CALL
WHEN WE WERE IN A CAMPAIGN MODE
AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN,
UNSOLICITED, AND I'VE DONE 30
HOURS OF TESTIMONY IN FRONT OF
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
I'VE HAD ALL OF THOSE SAME
JOURNALISTS SAY THAT I COMMITTED
TREASON ON LIVE TELEVISION FOR
YEARS, BUT HUNTER BIDEN?
NO SMOKE.
EVEN WITH THE JOHN SOLOMON STUFF
COMING OUT, IT'S GOOD TO SEE IT,
BUT YOU THINK IF I TOOK A 20
MINUTE MEETING FROM AN
UNSOLICITED PHONE CALL THAT
MERITED 30 HOURS OF TESTIMONY IN
FRONT OF THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE, WITH EVERYONE BASICALLY
THE ONLY -- TRYING TO GET YOU
FOR PERJURY, YOU THINK HUNTER
BIDEN SHOULD AT LEAST GOING TO
SOMETHING.
I THOUGHT RAND PAUL NAILED IT AT
THE RALLY WHEN HE SAID JUST
THAT.
IT'S TIME AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SICK OF THIS, SEAN.
>> Sean: I LOVE THE WORK
TRIGGERED, AND IT'S THE PERFECT
WORD AND I'M READING A BOOK,
IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY WELL DONE.
I GIVE YOU A LOT OF CREDIT.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY AND YOU CAN GO TO
WHEREVER YOUR WEBSITE IS AND
PEOPLE CAN GO SEE YOU.
BUT HERE'S THE THING:THINK OF
NICHOLAS SANDMANN.
HE WEARS A MAGA HAT.
NEITHER YOU OR I WOULD SHOW AS
MUCH RESTRAINT AS HE DID IN THAT
SITUATION.
>> NOT EVEN CLOSE.
>> Sean: I WOULDN'T PUT UP
WITH THAT AND NORWOOD YOU.
THE KID DID IT RIGHT.
HE'S GOING TO BE A BILLIONAIRE,
HE MIGHT BE RICHER THAN YOUR DAD
AT THE END OF THIS.
>> LISTEN, WITHOUT QUESTION,
THIS IS THE STUFF I GET INTO IN
THE BOOK.
I LITERALLY GO THROUGH AT LENGTH
THE HYPOCRISY OF THE MEDIA, THE
SHADOW BANNING FROM SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIORS AND THE
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES THAT ARE
DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
PRESENT THAT MESSAGE FROM
GETTING OUT, STYMIE THE MESSAGE
OF SUCCESS, OF VICTORY, OF ALL
TIME LOW UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS.
OF ALL TIME HIGH STOCK MARKET
NUMBERS.
EVERY ASPECT OF THIS ECONOMY IS
TURNING AND THEN YOU SEE THE
MEDIA REALLY TRYING SO HARD JUST
TO DESTROY THAT, TRYING SO HARD
TO TRY TO DISCREDIT IT.
THEY ARE LITERALLY TRYING TO
TURN THE ECONOMY, SO FOR YEARS
PEOPLE SAID MAYBE YOU SHOULD
WRITE THE BUSINESS BOOK AND I
SAID NO, MY DAD HAS THAT TOTALLY
COVERED, BUT WHEN YOU'VE BEEN
THROUGH WHAT I'VE BEEN THROUGH
IS THE NUMBER TO A TARGET OF THE
MUELLER HOAX, OF THAT JOKE, THAT
$40 MILLION FARCE --
>> Sean: JERRY GAVE YOUR OWN
RUN FOR YOUR MONEY AND BEAR AND
GAVE YOU A RUN FOR YOUR MONEY,
YOU'VE BEEN PACKING YOUR
FAMILY --
YOUR BROTHER.
>> I GET TO WATCH THE MEDIA
PERSONALITIES TALK ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN IS OFF LIMITS BECAUSE HE'S
FAMILY.
IF HE IS A 50-YEAR-OLD CORRUPT
BUSINESSMAN WITH NO BUSINESS
BEING ON ANY OF THOSE BOARDS IS
OFF LIMITS, 13-YEAR-OLD BARREN
TRUMP SHOULD BE OFF-LIMITS.
I CERTAINLY WASN'T OFF-LIMITS
FOR OBVIOUSLY A LOT LESS WITH A
LOT LESS SMOKE AND WHEN WE
WEREN'T ACTUALLY EVEN EMPOWER,
AND THAT'S THE SICKNESS THAT'S
THERE.
THAT'S WHY I DID THIS BOOK,
THAT'S WHY WE GET INTO DETAIL
AND IT GIVES A REAL OPPORTUNITY
TO GO INTO LONG FORM.
IF THERE'S ONLY YOU CAN DO AN
INTERVIEW WHETHER IT'S HERE,
RADIO OR OTHERWISE, BUT IT
ALLOWS ME TO TAKE 300 PAGES TO
GO THROUGH IN DETAIL OF ALL OF
THE STUFF, THEY CAN GO TO
TRIGGERED A BOOK.COM, THEY CAN
CHECK OUT ALL THE PLACES WE ARE
GOING TO BE AROUND THE COUNTRY
IN NEW YORK, FLORIDA,
CALIFORNIA, TEXAS WHERE WE ARE
GOING TO DO STOPS AND SEE THESE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN SO AWESOME.
THE BOOK IS LITERALLY DEDICATED,
SEAN, I THINK YOU WILL
APPRECIATE THIS TO THE
DEPLORABLES BECAUSE MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT STUCK WITH US FROM
MOMENT ONE --
>> Sean: GUILTY.
>> YOU WERE THERE TOO, I GET IT.
>> Sean: A SMELLY WALMART
SHOPPER, COSTCO SHARPER, AND I
CLING TO GOD IN HEAVEN.
I DO.
I BELIEVE IN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, THE BIBLE IS
MY RELIGION.
I AM GUILTY AS CHARGED.
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHI
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHG
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHW
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHO
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHG
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHW
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHT
>> Sean: >> THERE'S NOTHH
IT.
>> Sean: THOSE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WILL GO OUT AND REELECT
YOUR DAD -- LET'S SAY THEY
IMPEACH HIM, NOT GETTING
CONVICTED, WILLIE BROWN IS
RIGHT.
MANY AMERICAN PEOPLE -- LOOK, I
WAS IN CHICAGO AND DETROIT THIS
WEEKEND, THEY ARE PISSED OFF.
THEY ARE SICK OF THIS, THREE
YEARS, NEVER ENDING LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, ANOTHER
HOAX.
EVERYONE I MET, THEY ARE FED UP.
SEEMS LIKE IT WILL CRAWL OVER
BROKEN GLASS TO GET TO THE POLLS
ON ELECTION DAY.
>> THEY SHOULD BE AND YOU SEE IT
AND EVERYONE KNOWS, THIS
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY, IT STARTED
ON NOVEMBER 9TH 2016, OKAY?
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WROTE THE
FIRST OP-ED 19 MINUTES AFTER HE
TOOK OFFICE IN JANUARY OF 2017,
MAKING THE CASE FOR IMPEACHMENT.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOREVER.
THEY CAN'T ACCEPT THAT HE WON
THIS ELECTION, THAT HE BEAT THE
ANOINTED ONE, HILLARY CLINTON,
WHO IN ALL FAIRNESS, LET'S FACE
IT, HAD NO BUSINESS EVER RUNNING
THIS COUNTRY.
HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB AND HAS
DONE A GREAT JOB BY
UNPRECEDENTED INCOMING, SEAN.
>> Sean: THE BOOK, WE WILL PUT
IT UP AGAIN.
NOW OUT IN BOOKSTORES
EVERYWHERE, Hannity.com,